Richard Boyle says hi dr. Peterson how
does this score of 91 for compassion and
1 for politeness equals a score of 35
for agreeableness yeah well it's because
91 and 1 aren't ordinary numbers they're
percentiles and you can't just average
percentiles it doesn't work that way
what it says is that let's see I don't
know if I can generate at just a
description on the fly because I'm not I
wouldn't say I'm particularly
mathematically gifted although I know
that the answer I just gave you is
correct let's see there's a 1 in there's
a 1 in 10 chance that a person would be
that compassionate and a 1 and a hundred
percent chance that a person would be
that that that nope I can't generate it
on the fly but that's the answer so if
you want to point to the proper
literature you'd look up how to
transform percentiles into z-scores
they're called z-scores then you can if
you oh that's how it works you convert
the percentiles into z-scores you some
the z-scores and then you re convert
them into percentiles and so if you take
the z-score for naught for compassion 91
and the z-score for politeness 1 add
them divide them into Andry convert them
to a percentile you'll get 35 I know
it's weird but that's that's how it
that's how it is that's how it's done